you look so gorgeous in your quarantine
and you I mean how are you doing
I'm great I have to say I'm enjoying the
time being home because my kids are home
my husband's home and we're usually all
scattered so I'm looking at the
positives and I'm so happy to be home
with my family
yeah I love that about you so all the
kids are with you because I know the
last time that we talked I mean you had
kids in different states
you had your daughter in her own
apartment so what I loved one out of
state I've got two home oh wow okay so
one of your son's is out of state yeah
how was that for you are you kind of
freaking out or I'm not freaking out but
we're monitoring it every day and he's
he's happy he wants to stay there okay
and he's he's safe and he's you know
he's doing everything he has to do but
you know shutting down like flying
within states within the country then
Mama's gonna bring him home
yeah absolutely where is he right now
what's even Minnesota he's in Minnesota
okay Wow what are you guys kind of doing
to pass the time right now well we are
cooking so much at home I know you have
your cookware line I do have a cookware
line but we are like it's we're taking
the time to cook all the kinds of
recipes that we never do because they
take too long and now we have tons of
time so we're like opening all the
cookbooks that we never hump it and it
smells so good in my house right now
it's my husband's cooking and what did
he making right now I think he's making
lentils like a lentil stew Lucius yeah
we've been made I've been making I made
like this really good quinoa and black
bean taco salad it was vegetarian but
I've been in a bunch of cookbooks and it
was so delicious lots of different
veggies and then the quinoa and the
black
tasted like taco meat yeah what do you
and and the kids kind of make of
everything that's going on right now I
mean are you kind of surprised by
everything are you worried about future
what's going through your mind well you
know I think it's it's hard not to worry
to some extent but I'm not a big warrior
by Nature because there are things that
are just out of our control and that's
not gonna do any of us any good to worry
about it obviously we have to take
precautions we can think about the
future there's lots to think about but
just to sit and worry does nothing so I
always look to the positive and I always
recognize that God's in control and
there's nothing that surprises God in
the world and that's where my my faith
really helps me get through trying times
like this and so they're gonna be
changes and I tell my kids there's gonna
be changes and and and life may be
different after this we don't know but
we're gonna we're gonna take it as it
comes and we're gonna figure it out and
there aren't just a bunch of problems in
life there's solutions yeah yeah in a
sense do you feel like your family's
almost getting closer throughout this
time because you're spending so many
hours you're not off on set filming
right now obviously yeah
really that's what I'm really enjoying
the takeaway from this whole pandemic
which is awful that but we get to have
conversations we get to talk we get to
be close and spend time that we wouldn't
have had together and I think that all
families can look to that and and
friends and I realize there's people
that are sitting in their home alone too
and that feels aysil it so much more
isolated and can feel awful but that's
what is amazing about social media and
the internet and television is that
we're all not
never really alone we all have one
another in the world is so much smaller
because of it so you know I think we're
all we're all rooting the whole world on
you know we're all there for each other
and that's a positive thing we're all in
it together mm-hmm
any challenges that you're experiencing
that I'm eating too much yep all the
snacks right all this maps all the
cooking is great you know we we live in
sunny Southern California so we're still
able to go outside we've been taking
Heights we've been going on walks along
the beach and that's been really nice
and we're still able to keep our
distance from everyone we're going in
more remote places so we're not
endangering other people or ourselves
but it's really nice to get outside I
think it's got to be very hard for
people that don't have that
accessibility go up to go outside and to
exercise and get fresh air as much but I
know that is kind of our saving grace
and I don't know other than that I'm
like we've just been playing puzzles or
like you know puzzles together we've
been playing board games we've been
watching Netflix we've been cooking
hiking biking and jogging like that's
what we've been doing and working out at
home doing my video apps well I was
going to ask you I know that you're big
into fitness so how are you kind of
getting exercising while at home like
are you using the at home like workout
apps right now yeah so I'm if you follow
me you know that I'm a huge Kiera Stokes
fan who is my fitness trainer but she's
in New York I'm in LA I don't see her a
person very often so I used her fitness
app okay and I've been using that
everyday at home and I love it I do that
regardless of being poor on the way to
weigh the future and the way to go yes I
love it it's a killer workout and and
then like to kind of get the extra
cardio in we've just been taking walks
outside and hi there let's talk about
how your projects are being affected by
this I mean
where you filming anything or is
anything kind of being put on pause
right now with hallmark or kind of
walking through that yeah so we were in
the middle of filming a new Aurora
Teagarden mystery for the hallmark
movies in a story's Channel and we got
in one one week of production and then
we were shut down okay and we were which
I was very happy about I thought that
was the most responsible decision and it
was what what the right decision it was
the right decision so I left Vancouver
and immediately came back home to my
family and you know we were all hoping
that within two weeks or three weeks
we'd start production back up but now
watching the news every day I don't I
don't see that happening and of course
that is I think that's the real struggle
with so many of us and and the fear and
the worry is our jobs where so many of
us are not able to go and work and we're
restricted from doing that so we think
about all the bills that we have to pay
and our our mortgage and our food and
and everything and that affects every
single person no matter what your
position is no matter what your job is
and that's the unknown part that's scary
absolutely I mean you're such a positive
light do you have a message to families
out there who are worried and and
stressed right now like what would you
say to them where we're all worried and
I know that our country you know we pull
together we pull together for one
another and we all just have to do our
part and I know that I'm I'm praying for
all of us and I'm also you know looking
at the organizations that I'm that I'm
working with and talking to them and
saying what can we do for people
well can we do for people that aren't
going to be able to pay their bills and
hopefully you know the government where
I'm watching the news every day
gonna kick in and they're gonna waive
mortgage fees or your water bill or gas
bill for whatever this period of time is
I hope and pray that that happens
because this is affecting everyone but
you know in in light of things we still
have to think about the fact that many
of us have roofs over our head
many of us have homes we have clean
water we have the accessibility to get
groceries it may not it might not be
what we want exactly but compared to the
the entire world we are such a rich rich
country and a rich people
yeah very privileged like the level of
what that is - you going back to
Hallmark they are running a marathon of
Christmas movies did you see that cheer
what will I know will you guys be tuning
in and what did you make of that news
well I was delighted to hear I have many
many fans reaching out on social media
saying please show the Christmas movies
they are not happy so it's happy that
Hallmark heard the message and they're
gonna run them I think my my husband and
my children will kick me out of the
house if I turn my Christmas movies on
like we deal with this once a year with
you like we're not doing this at March
we're not you only get to cover I I
don't think I'm gonna turn them on but
I'm all tweet along though with people
as long as they don't have to watch it
but let's face it I made it I know what
happens I can happily tweet along
without watching yeah that's so funny
you do have an Aurora Teagarden movie
coming out in April is that still
scheduled to air as planned it's still
scheduled to air I actually still have
to do some of the sound work on that
movie and also it or it got cancelled
and we're hoping that within the next
week or maybe even from home I can do
all the sound edits for it because
that's the only thing that's gonna hold
them
be up from airing is if we don't if
we're not able to lock sound so are you
gonna get like a at home microphone
recording kit is that kind of what you
guys are looking into right now we're
taught we're talking about things so
we'll see what can be delivered yeah
when do you think I know you said you
thought it was gonna be a couple weeks
are there meetings happening where
you're like okay maybe in two months
we'll get back to work
three months is there a timeline at all
right now there isn't because the news
is changing everyday we're getting all
these updates and it's getting pushed so
it's really hard to plan anything but
we're all in communication and at this
point it's a waiting game I don't think
we're gonna have answers for at least
another ten days yeah I know it's scary
look I let you go and thank you so much
by the way for taking the time to do
this with us and share updates I know
people are gonna love to hear your
positivity and your messages we do want
to do a little rapid fire with you if
you're ok with that person yeah great
okay so first of all your go to
quarantine snack foods I've been trying
not to snack this is the problem but
there are these they're these these sumo
oranges out right now they're like a
Mandarin and they're so delicious and
yummy and so that's my sweet treat
yeah I love that you're healthy that
you're being healthy when everyone else
is like Oreos and cookies and I don't
have it in my house I don't buy it I
can't eat it okay you mentioned but you
guys are watching Netflix so what are
you binging right now oh well actually
yesterday watch two Lou I watched little
fires over yeah
yes little what is it little fires
everywhere little fires everywhere I
watched three episodes of that yesterday
it was great I was gonna say what do you
think of it it's Reese amazing Kerry
Washington both my favorites I love them
and I have to say the girl that plays
the Reese's oldest daughter in it
reminded me so much of DJ Tanner in the
90s I was kind of
hang out because just not so much her
face but just the clothes the hairstyles
like they did an amazing job to bring it
back to the 90s and every time I looked
at her I just thought DJ I thought DJ
Tanner and Steve Urkel with her
boyfriend like that's what I thought I
love that that's hilarious
Bryson I should say Jaleel White not
Steve Urkel but really oh yeah what
other hobbies are you kind of taking up
right now anything you're we going back
to other activities what's going on well
this has given me time to replant my
garden that I have although I haven't
been able to go to the store to get
seeds but we ripped the old garden I
have some new books that I bought on
composting cuz I have not tried that yet
and I'd like to start doing that so
that's the new hobby that I'm getting
into I love that Candace Cameron the
gardener yep and then oh what's your
current live at home outfit like what
are you hanging out in are you sweating
I'm pretty much in sweats or jeans and a
t-shirt in a sweatshirt I've got my
blessed day ever
shirt I always have positive messages on
my shirts and I'm pretty much yeah
living in my Lululemon leggings or some
sweatpants it's kind of nice right it is
this is the first time I put makeup on
in five days and it's been so nice I
haven't I haven't blow-dried my hair I
mean I did today but I just it's been
all natural and it's been wonderful yeah
our skin is at least appreciating that
right yep yeah before I let you go
anything that you want to say to your
fans who are watching anything you you
want to add oh well I mean again we're
all in this together
and God's control and there's nothing
that surprises him so stay strong read
your Bible yeah and just know that we're
only a click away on the TV or on your
on the computer and let's just laugh
through this and think of all the good
things and the positive things that we
can take away from this time that we're
together
[Music]